depuis le début de cette émission nous
sommes au sein de la société mécanique
ateliers de poignard une entreprise
spécialisée dans la mécanique de
précision
plus de 80% de son activité est réalisée
dans le secteur de l'aéronautique
cette pme de 26 collaborateurs et
dirigée par jorge da costa venez on va
le rejoindre
[Musique]
je
bonjour jorge da costa bonjour
[Musique]
en quoi consiste votre activité et
comment avez vous été impacté par la
crise sanitaire
alors notre société consiste à usiner
des pièces mécaniques
nous avons malheureusement été impactés
très fortement sur la crise sanitaire où
on nous a vendu même arrêté la
production pendant quinze jours le temps
de pouvoir pourri des solutions de
protection auprès de nos collaborateurs
et raturer nos clients qu'on repartait
en production derrière avec les moyens
efficace on a perdu malheureusement 30%
de notre chiffre d'affaires
alors quelle pièce vous fabriquez par
exemple on fabrique des pièces
essentiellement sur le secteur
aéronautique qui vont directement pour
dassault aviation ou d'autres
équipementiers et ce sont des pièces
soit de structures ou des pièces autour
du moteur alors vous voyez
essentiellement des centres d'usinage
à commande numérique des tours à
commandes numériques et des machines à
des coupes aux filles alors ce sont des
moyens qui sont préparés en amont via
des logiciels de cfao et qui met les
programmes on simule en amont et après
on transforme les matières on les ajuste
on les punit manuellement toute façon
automatique
elles sont contrôlées par maud la bo de
contrôler après livrés aux clients vous
êtes un sous traitant de rang 1
on travaille en direct cette fois avec
gâteaux ou thales et des grands donneurs
d'ordre ou
on leur assure la traçabilité des
produits la crainte permanente on a
refait les temps
vous retrouvez des casquettes de visée
laser ou en fait et des systèmes de
détection de nuit pour pour pouvoir
observer
vous avez également des supports de
cartes électroniques on retrouve en fait
donc là c'est vraiment sur du
développement ou donc en fait après il
vient d'implanter la carte électronique
tous les connecteurs qui viennent se
connecter sur le sur le cadre et ça
vient directement comme si c'était un
rack 2u une belle informatique
on sait très bien qu'un avion il peut
pas s'arrêter sur un parking s'il ya une
défaillance et que malheureusement il
peut y avoir des crachats ce moment donc
notre industrie a un vrai rôle
aujourd'hui de soutien aux fabricants de
ces produits dans le secteur
aéronautique
la région vous a sélectionné pour
obtenir une subvention de 450 mille
euros à quoi va servir cette enveloppe
est est-ce que c'est complémentaire d'un
investissement vous allez faire vous
même alors oui ça va être
complémentaires nous on va engager à 1
investissement de presse du million
d'euros qui va permettre de moderniser
notre outil de production de
correspondre en ténue mais au standard
de demain de lusine 4.0 ou les gros
donneurs d'ordres vont attendre de leurs
fournisseurs ce positionnement
donc en fait vous allez développer votre
vos outils qui sont déjà présents ici
c'est ce qu'on a fait on va compléter
nos outils aujourd'hui qui sont déjà
opérationnels on va les automatiser avec
des robots on va racheter les machines
qui seront eux déjà complètement équipée
en robot il y aura essayé de
standardiser cette façon de faire est
aujourd'hui on va essayer de se
reconvertir sur le secteur ferroviaire
ou unitaire ou peut-être automobile
merci georges da costa vous en prie
merci à vous d'être venu nous rencontrer
les dirigeants de mécanique ateliers de
coignières et maintenant prenons la
direction de guyancourt au sein de la
société gamme et car cette société a
aussi obtenu une aide de la région pour
accélérer la digitalisation de son
activité et acquérir de nouveaux marchés
[Musique]